non on va parler de la légendaire
madonna qui a tout juste 60 ans vient
d'annoncer alors là tous les fans sont
en transe un nouvelle tournée mondiale
dans la continuité du nouvel album
qu'elle vient de sortir on regarde la
vidéo de cette annonce faite par la
madone elle même et on revient sur sa
carrière avec vous juste après ok allez
[Musique]
paris
[Applaudissements]
on peut dire ce qu'on veut quand même la
madonna ça il n'y a rien à dire
olivier donc madonna c'est une star
peut-être même la dernière star des
eighties qui est encore là bien en place
et en tant que star elle a quand même eu
des petits caprices de diva c'est normal
ben oui alors par exemple dans les
années 90 si un de ces tourneur qui
raconte qu'elle avait demandé dans sa
loge d'avoir des bouteilles d'eau d'une
marque peu connue même temps jusque là
bas serait way qu'elle a demandé 500
bouteilles
ah oui d'accord elle a besoin de
s'hydrater et puis aussi une scène
fameuse qu'on a vu dans le documentaire
in bed with madonna alors elle est en
coulisses il ya kevin costner qui vient
la féliciter il a une mauvaise idée de
lui it was need ça veut dire c'était car
c'était bien fait et à merci il s'en va
et desquels dès qu'il est parti le feu a
oui mais quand même genre très et elle
dit quelqu'un qui dit que mon spectacle
est bien fait il mérite pas d'être avec
moi
bon ce que ce qu'il faut dire quand même
à sa décharge c'est que bon ça ça a été
dans le film dont la terrible pour kevin
mais kevin qui est pas revanchard est
revenu à voire des années plus tard avec
sa fille et là sur scène elle lui a fait
ses excuses
plutôt qu'un accord traîne au classement
mais à la peur de rien de toutes
nouvelles avaient peur de rien donc
c'est une grande artiste assez clair
elle a beaucoup aussi fait parler d'elle
dans des dans des scandales divers et
variés et notamment alors quand elle est
venue en france on se souvient quand
même dedans tout cas d'une histoire avec
jacques chirac on sait pas trop ce qui
s'est passé il ya une histoire de petite
culotte
alors qu'il ya eu quelque chose avec
notre ancien président de la république
on aimerait tous avoir des plus le temps
alors on est en 87 madonna annonces sont
concernés manceau parc de sceaux
évidemment et maire de paris à l'époque
assistent aux concerts et un des clous
du spectacle si on peut dire c'est
qu'elle est en verve sa petite culotte
et qui rouge pour information et la
balance dans la foulée qui c'est qui la
récupère ses chichis
parce que le lendemain
elle va à l'hôtel de ville pour donner
un énorme chèque pour la fondation d'une
renault pour lutter contre le sida est
là donc c'est jacques chirac qui vient
la cei il apprend de façon tellement
comment dire celle que les journaux à
scandale dit ça il se passe quelque
chose
l'histoire est belle mais
malheureusement ou heureusement fin ça
n'est pas arrivé c'est pas vrai en fait
c'est comme le sait comme le blé avec
britney spears et du show business a
répété donc mais quand la légende est
belle savez ce que c'est bien sûr bien
sûr
bon il ya aussi alors évidemment madonna
c'est aussi les clips d'équipé
incroyable je suis absolument fan de ce
qu'elle a pu produire qui bouleverser un
peu le lésé la massonne que les gens des
clips sulfureux érotique torride elle
joue avec tous les tabous avec la
religion etc
est ce que note qui vous ont
particulièrement marqué là you're gone
skandal scandale avec le prieur vadis
making la queue par ailleurs qu'à douai
lambres à sinsin enfin sai nt noir il ya
des crocs enflammé qui sont symboles du
klu klux klan saleh s'est plus en temps
madonna c'est satan toujours jouer avec
ça mais là c'est quand même pour dire le
vatican a quand même râler ah oui là la
paille il a pas excommunié mais presque
et sa lampe alors qu'elle est prêt les
haines et les coups très croyante noah
catholique mais bon comme vous dites
elle aime bien jouer clé symbole est la
run renouveler l'aventuré en 2006 là
c'était en concert elle était clairement
arrivé crucifié sur une croix
et encore une fois le vatican a dit non
là c'est impossible
après pas terrible mais mieux il ya du
sado maso si le film de justin
elle est magnifique magnifique réalisé
par mondino qu'un français où la cdu
bdsm des des chaînes des clowns
le clip met même type il avait censuré
la passe et que des années plus tard
c'est ce qui faisait aussi sa marque de
fabrique et c'est aussi pour ça que
c'était la sulfureuse madonna elle a
suscité le scandale partout y compris
quand elle a joué vite à évita peron
banque fim les argentins étaient
scandalisés mais ils ont eu tort parce
qu'en l'occurrence c'était peut-être son
meilleur rôle au cinéma c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai quand il faut rappeler
aussi que non
elle a réalisé elle a joué au cinéma en
tant que comédienne est calé en plus
chanteuse d'horloge et on rappelle donc
que cette année c'est celle du grand
retour de madonna tellement attendu par
les fans on a vu le clip medellin
l'album annoncé s'appelle madame x on a
entendu le dire la dent dans les sujets
et on peut résumer c'est presque
quarante ans de carrière en quelques
chiffres 2 et j'imagine des chiffres
records alors évidemment puisque avec
une fortune estimée à environ 800
millions de dollars c'est la femme la
plus riche du show business c'est pas
mal ça vaut le coup d'avoir deux trois
trucs en cloud et le hamas arrête ça
veut dire quand même 300 millions de
disques vendus plus gros ce chanteuse
ont deux selon le guinness book bien
cumuler de ses tournées 1,4 milliard de
dollars
et c'est la seule femme du rock à avoir
fait deux concerts de plus de 100000
personnes n'ont à rio et l'autre et bah
c'était le concert du parc de sceaux
puisqu'il y avait plus de cent vingt
mille spectateurs à c'est-à-dire
qu'elles rivalisent avec les rolling
stones en fait car elle toute seule
carrément voilà vous considérez quand
même que cette allée j'allais dire
l'icône pop des années 80 un
indéboulonnable pensée pour pour vous
c'est la plus grande
y'a pas photo am r kiki peut faire mieux
que madonna qui a fait des scènes comme
celle de badauds de madonna de deux
soeurs sing for suzanne où elle c'est
pile dessous le risque d'appel
c'est aussi exactement elle est
formidable et ça fait 40 ans que ça dure
quand il pourvoit elle va durer encore
longtemps madonna a peut-être que
bientôt ça va être un peu moins sexy un
peu plus chanson mais elle est quand
même on a vu les images quand même à 60
ans fanny d'entendre l'album on a hâte
d'entendre l'album et de la voir sur
scène alors que sur scène être en grand
rex au malawi vous allez prendre vos
billets pour le grand rex où j'espère
être invitée mais je la vois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gratos ok merci j'avais des chansons
préférées de deux lames à tous
on en attend on en parlait à l'instant
don't cry for me a story dont le suspect
au mercy la dame et o2 et guitare qui
raconte la vie des victimes
les poils du mans au garde à vous si
vous tentez de bras ça va like a virgin
ah bah oui samedi pour sa damien donc
c'est cool c'était sa première c'était
la poule à le premier gros deal c'était
génial là on voit ça bouge plus et give
it to me avec pharrell
on va terminer la bonne
[Musique]
moi j'en cache pas que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'admiration
et de tendresse pour madonna je pense
que c'est quand même une des reines de
la pop
merci beaucoup